well the sun's finally out after this
weekend store rent show down for too bad
you'll be in the office okay happy
Monday now over the traffic thanks miles
as for traffic you're screwed yeah I
don't even like coffee I just wait for
it to brew to avoid work for 30 minutes
that's smart
I go to the bathroom multiple times a
day and I just scroll through social
media for like 20 minutes
hello who just joined it's Tammy
hey Tammy I heard you were sick thanks
for joining anyway I decided to stay
home and binge watch TV I'm just using
this weird voice to make my illness seem
credible yeah it's not that convincing
but honestly none of us care well
actually I care because I miss you hmm
that's not a secret
hey you want to grab lunch let me check
my to-do list sure what so what do you
guys do this weekend I played a bunch of
video games swiped right on a hundred
and seventy six dating profiles didn't
get a match but I'm sorry I was gonna do
laundry but I forgot so instead I err
fresh in the stink out of this shirt yep
John I spent the entire weekend with my
two-year-old so glad it's Monday
[Music]
weekends are for slackers
yeah you got something minutes